let's see if we can chat with a couple
of other people how about connor from
atlanta georgia connor welcome
how you doing david i'm doing well
awesome um so
i wanted to ask exactly um
about biden running in 2024 for a second
term
um
if if
people who um because i'm i'm more of a
centrist i don't really
um i'm a little
conflicted about the 2024 election right
now because i guess the running up for
the republicans are um
as ron desantis i don't think trump
stands a chance running again
um i don't know if
biden would be good enough for a second
term just simply because of his
cognitive ability currently
um so what exactly do you think on that
because i don't i don't know if um i
just don't i'm just very conflicted
right now for 2024. well listen
speculations about cognitive ability
aside i just don't think joe biden's
running in 2024. he's i don't think he's
interested in it um i think he would
have a very tough time winning
he'll be 82. i just i just don't think
he's going to run and i know people say
but david he keeps saying his intention
is to run yeah i know his intention is
to run and i don't think he's going to
do it so i don't think you're going to
end up in a situation quite frankly
where you'll have to
figure out how you feel about joe
biden's cognition i think he's just not
going to be a candidate
well who do you think should be the
running up then
listen i think there's a lot of people a
lot of rising stars in the democratic
party we've talked about gavin newsom's
political skill i've mentioned i really
like jamie raskin i like stacy abrams i
like john ossoff i think pete budege
would do
really well now that he has more name
recognition maybe not right away maybe
it's we've got to wait another cycle or
two for him but i think there's a lot of
really smart people who would be
good in terms of the performance piece
of what it takes to be president
what about uh um it's funny you
mentioned john ossoff and say favorite
stacey abrams because i do live in
georgia
um what do you think of uh warnock
yeah i mean i think that his his
demeanor i i love him personally i think
that something about his demeanor maybe
seems like a less obvious
win
compared to some of the other people i
mentioned uh but he he's very skilled i
just don't think he's yet as skilled
politically as some of the other folks i
mentioned
mm-hmm right right do you think we
should get a um
a democratic president in there who's um
religious
is because raphael warnock comes from a
religious background
yeah i mean um
listen i don't i don't know at this
point whether that really matters you
sort of have to play to religiosity but
i don't think you have to pretend to be
deeply religious
necessarily it just has to be plausible
that you like you follow a religion i
think it's going to be less and less of
an issue over time although still for
the evangelical voters in particular it
really does matter
right right okay i see
well that's all i needed david thank you
all right thanks connor very much
appreciate that all right everybody
that's going to do it for today
we don't have time for more calls today
but we will in the future and i hope to
hear from people next time thank you for
joining me we'll take a quick break and
be right back